this is a new sort of video for me
usually I just recorded with my built-in
computer webcam for this video I wanted
to do something a bit different actually
today just a few hours ago a package
arrived in the mail Amazon Prime and
this is actually the first time that
I've been sent a package from a fan so
I'm gonna open it and see what's inside
ooh look at this I still don't know what
it is it just says surprise keep your
gift of surprise unwrap your present
before opening this envelope okay so
this is what it looks like so far still
have no idea what it is open further Wow
so it's wrapped and it's wrapped in this
thing I still don't know what it is I
don't want to shake it could be valuable
hopefully it's not like an animal some
sort it's not even really any sound
hi Eric enjoy your gift it's from an
anonymous fan from the noggin people can
see that anyone who watches me
consistently should know who the noggin
is wow this is interesting how do I I'm
bad with knots actually no I'm pretty
good with knots there we go I don't want
to like rip this this is such nice
wrapping I might have to rip it
how do I get this undone or not so sorts
like wrap through whatever this is just
a troll to make me run around something
impossible to unwrap whoa
people can see there's more wrapping
inside hey this is not what I was
expecting but this is actually really
exciting look at this
it's a teapot set I don't even know how
to pronounce this ke ke Don Lakota kini
four pieces stainless steel it was my
teacup I had my tea cup right here
I had to move it out of tea for the time
being but not for long so I open this
further yeah let's see what's inside and
struggling with the bosses Wow so here's
a top here is I think the kettle another
Wow I will say this is actually going to
be very useful one more thing
instruction booklets because usually
when I make my tea I just put the teabag
like in the cup and one tea bag is worth
one cup but now I can put the teabag in
this thing and I'll make more than one
cup of tea at a time one tea bag these
look very high-quality I really
appreciate it thanks to whoever the
anonymous subscriber is I think I got
through everything
oh wait I'll keep your gift to surprise
unwrap your present before opening this
envelope so I'm going to open this
envelope and see what's inside
new dealers and notes went wrong to use
keys to open an envelope a for you yeah
it's the same message well thank you so
much and thank you to everyone I do want
to express my gratitude towards the
people even the people who haven't sent
me any gifts who have watched online who
give your feedback and your comments
across twitch and YouTube and all the
other social platforms I will be
continuing to do more content so stay
tuned and thank you once again